build-it draw plane
Vsauce this is your home for some of the
coolest creations from everyday people
this is speedy building the visitor is
an alien robot kinetic sculpture by Nemo
Gould he used a typewriter case voltage
meters laboratory beaker and more to
create this his latest addition to a
large portfolio of repurposed object
kinetic sculptures meanwhile Kyle built
a functioning skee-ball machine out of
connects it has a coin mechanism that
accepts quarters scores points with a
counter has a system to return the ski
balls and it turns itself off when the
game is over it took over a year to
build and uses six normal motors to
power
David ma creates sculptures out of
matchsticks his series titled match
heads to pick the heads of animals
African masks and skulls as well as
celebrities like Charlie Chaplin and
Marilyn Monroe he starts with plastic
molds and then covers them with live
match heads imported from Japan for
their unique colors and James price took
a scrapped Boeing 737 and rebuilt it
into a flight simulator it's taken over
ten years so far to recreate the cockpit
and a software runs explains ten he uses
six computers to run the many different
systems and basically everything inside
this thing is wired up and works fine
the link below to learn more
draw Christian far creates intricate
pixelated portraits out of stacked
crayons
he starts by scanning a photo into a
computer and breaking down the image
into colored blocks then draws a grid to
show him exactly where to place each
crayon the thousands of crayons being
packed into frames which can take
several days to stack space painter is
the YouTube channel of spray paint
artist Brandon McConnell he has almost
200 videos of his surreal sci-fi
landscape paintings and also has some
instructional videos for aspiring
artists finally below to check out his
channel and now for some art from the
Breaking Bad art project finally Randy
Albion is a digital artist from Thailand
with some incredible fan art including
Pikachu street fighter and a bunch from
Final Fantasy playin brentalfloss
specializes in adding lyrics to video
game music here's his song for bioshock
aquatic night man drones are known to
freely roam with little sisters who
require the help I mean to tell you
plainly mister if that thing that was my
sister I believe I disowned myself
direct from Portugal here's what dubstep
or electro house sounds like when played
on guitar specifically bangarang by
Skrillex
[Music]
the synth axe was created in the 80s and
is a threaded guitar like MIDI
controller and it sounds like this
[Music]
finally tayzonday and mike diva combined
forces for supernova mainframe submit
your own PDP's as a personal message
here on youtube or share them with
everyone over at facebook.com slash
vsauce gaming
[Music]
click here listen to a brand new
installment of bdp radio music created
and submitted by you guys also check out
your bidipi
an entire video dedicated to your
creations and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]
you